>> ♪ ♪
>> HAPPY FRIDAY EVERYBODY.
I'M SO EXCITED, FIRST FOR THAN A
WELCOME'S GUESTS.
THE GAS.
SHE'S GUESSING FOR TWO.
THIS CHRISTMAS SHE IS EATING FOR
TWO, AND SHOPPING FOR BILL.
"FOX & FRIENDS" FOR COSO'S
CURRENTLY I AM SO PREGNANT
JENKINS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> HE IS SO OUT FOLKS SPOKEN
HE LEAVES THE LIVES BROKEN
SOCIAL SCIENTISTS HALTED.
>> SHE IS SO GREEN, SHE
RECYCLES ALL HER MAIL, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR CAPTAIN.
AND, FINALLY, SANTA ACCUSED HIM
OF BLOCKING HIS AIRSPACE, MY
MASSIVE PSYCHIC AT THE END OF
THE WAY IT HAD TO BE A CHAMPION
TYRUS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
I, BEFORE YOU BEGIN AND GET TO
SOME NEW STORIES IT'S FRIDAY, SO
IT IS TIME FOR THE LIFE PIE
EATING CONTEST WITH THE
AUDIENCE.
>> KNOW I WAS JOKING.
IT'S TIME FOR THIS.
>> ♪ ♪
>> GREG'S LEFTOVERS.
YES, IT'S TIME FOR LEFTOVERS OR
I READ THE JOKES THAT WE DID NOT
USE THIS WEEK.
AND AS ALWAYS IS OF MICE MY
FIRST TIME READING THEM FOR HERE
WE GO.
FIRST OFF, FORMER FREDERICK
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL HAS BEEN
FIRED AFTER MULTIPLE ARRESTS FOR
SWIPING LUGGAGE AS AN AIRPORT.
POLICE SAY IF YOU RECOGNIZE THE
CLOSE BRINGS IN AS YOUR OWN, GET
IN A STYLUS.
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
STEALING U.S. SENATE ELECTED IN
A NEW NETFLIX TIME JOHN LOT
STARTING CHRIS MANN BAIL TO
RELEASE NEXT MONTH, DURING A GO
THROUGH ROBBERY PLAYS A WALL OF
STOLEN VEGETABLE.
DON'T CLAP.
NO.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
TERRIBLE PEOPLE.
>> I'M ASHAMED OF MY AUDIENCE.
THE FDA HAS APPROVED A NEW PILL
THAT TREATS DIABETES IN CATS.
IT COMES IN A SPECIALLY DESIGNED
BOTTLED IS EASIER TO PUSH OFF
THE KITCHEN COUNTER.
IT IS FUNNY REALLY?
AS A COURTESY LEFT.
DO YOU I WILL SEE WHAT WE DO TO
WRITERS?
WHO WRITE REALLY BAD JOKES?
THIS IS WHAT WE DO.
[WHIPLASH SOUND]
>> HOW DID YOU HAVE THAT?
>> BECAUSE I KNEW WOULD HAVE A
BAD JOKE.
FOR SOME REASON I CAN JUST KEEP
WATCH OF THAT I DON'T KNOW WHY,
A 90 OLD WOMAN FINALLY GRADUATE
FROM COLLEGE 71 YEARS AFTER
FIRST ENROLLING.
SHE SAYS HE HASN'T LANDED A JOB
YET BECAUSE HER FIRST QUESTION
IN EVERY NEW VIEW IS, WHEN YOU
SEE IS OFTEN FIVE YEARS?
>> [LAUGHTER]
>> NOW SHE PLANS TO SPEND THE
SUMMER BACK WORKING ACROSS
VILLAGES.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT'S FUNNY.
SHE'S ESPECIALLY THANKFUL HER OF
STUDENT LOANS WERE FORGIVEN BY
PRESIDENT COOLIDGE.
[LAUGHTER]
A TOILET USED BY JOHN LONDON AT
A MANSION HE SHARED WITH YOKO
ONO WILL BE PUT ON DISPLAY AT
LIVERPOOL MUSEUM.
FANS ARE THRILLED AS IT WILL
REMIND THEM OF HER MUSIC.
THAT IS SO GOOD.
ALTHOUGH SHE IS UNDERRATED BUT
THAT WAS FUNNY.
YOU ARE A SCIENTIST OF THEY
CREATED A NUCLEAR FREEZE YOUR
REACTION BY HEATING A TARGET TO
OVER 5 MILLION DEGREES.
UNTIL NOW OF COURSE, THE ONLY
THING TO REACH THAT TEMPERATURE
WAS THE McDONALD'S APPLE PIE.
WHAT'S UP WITH THAT?
SEVERAL U.S. ARMY SOLDIERS ARE
UNDER INVESTIGATION AFTER
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT PHOTOS OF
THEM, APPEARED ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
WEARING BONDAGE GEAR AND DOG
MASKS.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE THEM SIMPLY
DO A GOOGLE SEARCH FOR BIG BLACK
COP GETS PANELS.
[LAUGHTER]
YEAH, YOU JUST SAID IT.
THE WHALE, STARRING BRANDON
FRASER, HAS A SISTER TO PAUL
MAN, AND THE BIGGEST LIMITING
OPENING IN ANY YEAR IN L.A. THIS
WEEK.
IT ALSO EARNED PRAISE FOR BEING
THE FIRST FEATURE FILM TO BE
SHOT ENTIRELY IN A SIZZLER.
IS IT?
IT IS ALSO EARNED A GOLDEN GLOBE
NOMINATION FOR BEST SWEATPANTS.
[LAUGHTER]
AND DO WE REALLY NEED A
FOLLICLE?
I DON'T KNOW.
LET'S WATCH SOME MORE WHIPPING.
IN A NEW INTERVIEW, RYAN MURPHY
SAID HE STAND BY THE DAHMER
CITIES DESPITE BACKLASH, HE JUST
DIDN'T INCLUDE A SCENE OF
DAHMER'S FAVORITE RESTAURANT,
FIVE GUYS.
>> THAT, THAT WAS FUNNY.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND FINALLY, MY FOOD TAPE MY TWO
FAVORITE WORDS.
A STUDY FINDS THAT ONE MINUTE
BURST OF ACTIVITY DURING DAILY
TASK, COULD ACTUALLY PROLONGING
LIFE.
AND IF THE STUDY ISSUE?
JEFFREY TOOBIN WILL LIVE TO BE A
THOUSAND.
ALL RIGHT, BEFORE WE GET TO A
STORY, WE ALSO NEED TO DO THIS
LUCY'S ♪ ♪
GREG'S CORRECTIONS, NY, WE
SHOULD NEVER EVER DOUBT HIM
AGAIN.
YES, WAS THE NIGHT BY DISCUSSING
THEIR ARRESTS OF BANK BEEN
FEEDING THE BAHAMAS THIS
HAPPENED.
>> THIS IS WHAT I DO FOR MY
SOURCES IN THE BAHAMAS -- THAT
IT WAS STILL BEHIND ME ENDS, THE
BAHAMA UNION'S POLICE.
THAT ARRESTED HIM BECAUSE HE
OWED -- BOHEMIAN?
>> YES BOHEMIAN.
>> YOU DIDN'T KNOW THAT
>> BOHEMIAN?
BOHEMIAN.
>> ALL IT'S BEHIND ME AND?
>> IT IS NEVER BEEN THAT.
NO ONE EVER SAYS THAT.
>> OKAY BE QUIET EVERYBODY.
SHOULD HAVE EVERYBODY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> TURNS OUT, I WAS RIGHT AND
THEY WERE WRONG.
AS VERIFIED BY A WORLD
THAT.COM, QUOTE THE CITIZENS OF
THE BAHAMAS ARE KNOWN AS BAJA
MEANS.
NOW BOHEMIAN SPA HOBBYIST.
IN CONCLUSION, I AM THE SMARTEST
MAN ALIVE AND SHOULD NEVER BE
QUESTIONED BY ANYBODY IN ANY
TIME.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
QUIET, FINALLY, ONTO SOME ACTUAL
NEWS.
DISCLOSING ELON'S LOCATION
EARNED THEM A SEVEN DAY
VACATION.
ELON MUSK SUSPENDED ELISA HAVING
KNOWN A JOURNALIST YESTERDAY
ACCUSING THEM OF VIOLATING
TWITTER'S RULES AGAINST DOXXING.
SOME OF THE ACCOUNTS WERE BLOND
TO REPORTERS OR TWEETED ABOUT
THE BATTLE BETWEEN ELON'S IN A
COLLEGE FRESHMAN WAS TRACKING
THE TRIBE IT FIGHTS.
ELON SWEETING SAY THAT THEY
POSTED MY EXACT LOCATION
BASICALLY ASSASSINATION
COORDINATES.
AN OBVIOUS DIRECT VIOLATION OF
TWO IN TERMS OF SERVICE.
SEVEN DAY SUSPENSION FOR
DOXXING, SOME TIME AWAY FROM
TWITTER.
IT IS GOOD FOR THE SOUL.
>> THAT WAS GOOD.
KEITH OLBERMANN, REMEMBER THAT
GUY, KEITH OLBERMANN?
HE WAS THE HIGHEST PROFILE
PERSON TO BE SUSPENDED MEETING?
THERE WERE NO HIGH AMMO PROFILE
PEOPLE WERE SPENT SUSPENDED.
IN THOSE ALL THERE IS TO A
CARLY.
YOU KNOW I FEEL LIKE -- WE ARE
THE BROADCASTED VERSION OF THE
NATIVITY SCENE.
>> WHY QUESTION MAKES ME WANT
BECAUSE YOU'RE LIKE MARY WITH A
LITTLE BABY.
>> ALL I LIKE THAT.
>> WOULD YOU BE THE WISE MEN?
>> IN.
>> KNOW HE'S A BOROUGH.
>> ELICITED SaaS.
>> HARVESTED A LITTLE DRUMMER
BOY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YES, SO IT CARLY?
I'M GOING TO DEFEND ELON MUSK IN
SAYING THAT THIS WAS MORE ABOUT
HIS FAMILY THEN IT WAS ABOUT
POLICY.
WHAT YOU THINK?
SPAY WHAT I MEAN HE WAS MAD
BECAUSE APPARENTLY -- I MEAN HE
WAS DOXXED.
AND THEN HE WOUND UP IN A
STOCKING SITUATION.
SO, THIS IS INTERESTING ALSO
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT THESE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SUSPENDED YOU
CAN'T REALLY SEE EXACTLY WHAT
THEY TREAT US WITH HER TO.
WELL, I THINK THAT IF THEY
POSTED HIS LOCATION IN REAL
TIME, THEN THEY DESERVE TO BE
SUSPENDED.
BUT IF THEY JUST POSTED AN
ARTICLE ABOUT HIM GETTING DOXED,
THEN YOU SHOULDN'T TAKE IT
SUSPENDED.
>> SO THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
THERE.
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO SAY
ABOUT ELON IS THAT HE HAS BECOME
THE ULTIMATE TRAP LIKE FIGURE ON
TWITTER BECAUSE HE'S CHEWING
EVERYBODY, AND MAKING THEM LOSE
THEIR MINDS.
AND THEN YOU HAVE ALL THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE TWEETING, THAT IT
WILL BE THE LAST TWEET AND
THEY'RE LEAVING TWITTER, AND IS
POSITIVELY HILARIOUS.
>> TWEETING TWITTER LIKE A
RICH GUY TWEETS ABOUT.
SPAY WHAT I GOT A BOAT I'M JUST
A DRIVER ON THE BASE OF ALL MY.
>> LOOK AT A GIANT BOWL, HE'S
LIKE GERALDO.
AND THEN, AND THEN, IS LIKE
TWITTER IS HIS BOW.
HE'S JUST DRIVING THE BOAT
AROUND THE HARBOR SAYING HA HA
HA APPEAL YOU'RE OUT HERE.
I THINK IS BASICALLY GOING OKAY,
IF YOU KNOW MY LOCATION YOU'RE
GOING TO MY FAMILY LOCATION,
THAT IS DOXXING, SO I PUT THE
DATA CARD.
MAYBE WHAT YOU THINK QUESTION
MAKES ME WANT YES, THIS IS VERY
MURKY WATERS ARE DEALING WITH
HERE WHO'S THE LADY OUT IN
CALIFORNIA HANDLING THE FRITOS
LOOKS AGAIN IS MAN?
>> MAXINE WATERS.
>> I'M GLAD YOU KNEW THAT.
SPAY 100 GET THAT?
THEY HEAR.
>> YEAH.
>> I'M IN THE PAST TWO YEARS
SHE GOES AROUND AND SHE'S
BASICALLY AUTHORIZING AND
VIOLENCE AGAINST PONCHO
OFFICIALS ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
COMMUNISTS ARE RADICALS.
AND THEY HAVE A HISTORY OF BEING
RADICALIZED.
IT WAS STARTED TO SEE THAT
MANIFESTED THE MEAT ON THE
PROPAGANDA.
WERE IN DANGEROUS WATERS.
WHEN I THINK ABOUT THESE
GENERALISTS.
THE ONLY PUNISHMENT I CAN THINK
OF, IS THAT WITHIN TAPE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> PROBABLY IS THE PROBABLY
ENJOY.
>> IT DOES KIND OF APPEAR IN
HYPOCRITICAL, BUT IS IT REALLY
BECAUSE DOXXING IS ALWAYS
WRONG -- THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN PART
OF THE POLICY.
SO HIM -- IF IT'S ONLY TEN
TWITTER, IT'S PART OF THE RULES.
>> I MEAN IT IS A DEFINITION
OF HYPOCRITICAL.
BECAUSE, HE TWEETED LAST MONTH,
MY COMMITMENT TO FREE SPEECH IS
CLEANSING THE TEN NOT FANNING
THE ACCOUNT FOLLOWING MY PLANE.
EVEN AS A DIRECT PERSONAL SAFETY
REX.
SO HE SAID THAT, AND IS NOT
REALLY DOXXING BECAUSE IT'S
PUBLIC INFORMATION.
THAT'S WHY IT IS MURKY AS YOU
SAID BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHICH
MUSLIMS POST A COMMENT ON, BUT
NOW HE'S SAYING OKAY -- WHAT
SHOULD I UNDEAD THEM NOW ARE ON
THEN THEM IN SEVEN DAYS?
SO AS NOT AS THOUGH THEY BEING
FROM PERMANENTLY SUSPENDED,
DOXXING I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GIVE
IT A CALL AT THAT BECAUSE THIS
WAS PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION BUT I THINK THAT --
IF HE'S IN A STATE THAT HE CAN
DO WHATEVER HE WANTS -- IT IS
GOING TO BE A FREE SPEECH
ABSOLUTIST, THEN YOU SHOULDN'T
BE ALLOWING THAT.
BUT AGAIN, IF IT'S A SEVEN DAY
SUSPENSION IT IS GOING BACK ON
IT AND HE HAS THE ABILITY TO
CHANGE HIS MIND AFTER FEEDBACK,
I THINK IN ANY CASE THAT'S A
GOOD THING.
>> I MEAN I WOULD QUARREL WITH
YOU MILDLY OVER THE IDEA PUBLIC
INFORMATION BECAUSE EVERYTHING
IS ALMOST PUBLIC NOW.
YOU CAN FIND OUT MY PHONE NUMBER
OR FORTUNATELY, DON'T ME.
>> STOP POINTED OUT THERE.
I KNOW -- ALL RIGHT BEFORE WE
START -- YOU ARE SO PETTY.
>> I KNEW YOU WERE TO SAY
THAT.
>> KNOW -- ON WEDNESDAY NIGHT
HE SAT IN HIS LITTLE CABIN
SAYING THEY'RE SAYING I WAS
WRONG -- SENDING EMAILS OUT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
TO GET SORTED ABACK ABOUT.
[LAUGHTER]
SPAY WHAT IN MY DEFENSE, I DO
KNOW THAT'S WHAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE I WASN'T
LISTENING.
[LAUGHTER]
SPAY WAS VERY DISAGREEING WITH
THEM.
>> I WAS LIKE BOHEMIAN IS A
WORD -- SCALABLE YOU KNOW YOU
ARE JUST PETTY.
>> AND YOU WOULD JUST LIKE THE
LITTLE JOURNALIST.
BECAUSE, BEING SUSPENDED FOR
TWITTER, FOR SEVEN DAYS A MAN IF
I WAS A CHILD.
IT INSTEAD OF A MY MOTHER WAS
LIKE YOU'RE OFF TWITTER FOR
SEVEN DAYS, I BE LIKE PLEASE
DON'T MAKE IT TEN.
YOU DO, BUT THE REASON WHY HE
DID IT, WAS BECAUSE IT LED TO
SOMEBODY CRAZY STALKING HIM.
I'M HOPING THAT WOULD'VE
HAPPENED, PROBABLY REDUNDANT BUT
AGAIN, SEVEN DAYS.
IT'S A FURLED PORCH PUNISHMENT.
>> MY THING IS TO SEAL THE
COUNTRY GOING, IS PRETTY GOOD IF
YOU JUST TAKE A SEVEN-DAY BREAK.
THE MAIN -- HE'S BEING
FACETIOUS.
>> IT'S BAD AND HORRIBLE, SO
SHOULD BE THE BEST THING OVER TO
GET AWAY FROM 70s, BECAUSE WHY
DID THEY KEEP COMING BACK?
IF YOU WRITE THIS IS MY LAST
TWEET, IT MEANS THAT THIS IS NOT
MY LAST TWEET.
>> THAT HE ALWAYS TALKS ABOUT
OUR TIRES, POSTING A PICTURE OF
HIM CRYING JUST SO PEOPLE WILL
SAY YOU'RE SO BRAVE -- SPILLING
OUT ON I'LL NEVER TELL MY BOOT
VIEWERS TO TAKE A WEEK OFF OF
THIS SHOW.
BECAUSE I'M TOO GREEDY.
I NEED TO PAY OFF THE BOATS.
I CALL IT GERALDO SO.
>> JUST PETTY.
AS WELL RECALL THE SS PETTY.
[LAUGHTER]